the Prime Minister and Energy Secretary
Grant shaps at the UK's National nuclear
fusion research lab here to launch a
plan explaining how we will increase
energy security while also cutting
carbon emissions to Net Zero behind the
smiles though there is real pressure
building on this issue with America
launching a huge green subsidies package
to tempt investors over the Atlantic
your Chancellor Jeremy Hunt has said
today that it is a distortive global
subsidies race hasn't it cost us the
UK's lead on wind not yet and I'm
concerned that it doesn't or that it
shouldn't over the last decade or more
we've spent 50 percent more as a
proportion of our GDP than America on
Renewables I welcome the fact that
America have finally woken up to the
opportunities here and I hope we're
going to sell a lot of stuff too the
criticism is that the policies you
announced today are really just about
Target setting and framework and you are
closing your eyes and hoping the market
is going to do the rest
could not disagree more this this
country has a huge lead in
decarbonization that one of our European
neighbors can match by the way and
America is a decade behind the
government's plan explains that it wants
to phase out fossil fuels almost
entirely by replacing them with more
nuclear and Renewable Power there's also
help for consumers to reduce Demand with
expanded Home Heating and installation
schemes and there's more investment in
clean Technologies
the problem with some of the
technologies that feature significantly
in the government's plans is that
they're relatively untested hydrogen
small nuclear reactors carbon capture
and storage none of these things are
affordable yet or available at scale
and despite a court order forcing the
government to reveal more detail on its
Net Zero targets some critics say the
plan is short on new policies and new
cash it isn't enough as it stands how
are we going to make sure that we get
off gas for heating as quickly as
possible onto electric Technologies is
the money that they promised for
insulation enough to really help people
with their bills in the long run so this
is a step on but it's not the whole
journey
but others at the sharp end of the Green
Revolution are happy with the progress
absolutely massive news for our business
and for everyone around the country
we're in a an energy crisis we're in a
cost of living places so the government
investment and Energy Efficiency and
retrofit is massively welcomed by us
promises are one thing but now Net Zero
must actually be delivered a task
growing more complicated by the day
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News